100% tous eu les donneurs défilent ce
vendredi 11 juin les 90 créneaux
proposés ont vite trouvé preneur le
point commun des volontaires ils sont
pour la plupart des habitants de toussus
le noble
je suis à quelques minutes donc c'est
facile de s'y rendre vu que c'est plus
proche
je pense que les personnes de tous ceux
qui habitent ici ça incitera plus de
personnes à venir directement à côté de
chez eux
il ya eu quand même beaucoup
d'informations données à travers les
réseaux sociaux et les messageries
whatsapp donc automatiquement c'est plus
facile au départ de la mobilisation ivo
jeunesse de l'association cent pour sang
tous eu ce nobel tu soient obtenues
rapidement le soutien de la mairie pour
mettre à disposition l'espace culturel
du plessis le rôle de la section 100%
tous uc2 de fédérer les collectes enfin
de communiquer entre l'établissement
français du sang et l'amérique tout su
nous à titre de bénévoles d'organiser
comme on le peut l'ouverture de la porte
de la salle l'accueil des participants
dans la remise des bouteilles d'eau en
fin de balade est là elle est comment
dire les la campagne d'affichage de
boîtes âge ça a été extrêmement rapide
j'ai eu une première demande il ya un
mois de notre association 100% tout su
et la semaine suivante le fs était déjà
ici sur place avec nos services
techniques pour visiter les lieux pour
voir s'ils étaient adaptés à leurs
besoins et effectivement c'était le cas
donc en une semaine nous avons pu
organiser cette première collecte
la prochaine collecte est d'ores et déjà
prévu les équipes de bénévoles et de le
ffs donne rendez vous aux volontaires le
16 septembre prochain
l'établissement français du sang a
annoncé vouloir faire de
toussus-le-noble la collecte de
référence sur le secteur